الاسلام السياسي كان يزعم انه يريد ان
يؤوب بالحياه العامه الى الدين يريد ان
يؤب بالاقتصاد وبالسياسه وبالجيش والجهاد
وبالتعليم وبالاعلام وحتى بالعلوم البحته
وبمناهج التعليم هذه كانت مزاعم الاسلام
السياسي بانه اريد ان يحكم الناس ليطبق
هذا الاسلام الشمولي ولكن ثبت ان النظريه
خضراء الرماديه والتجربه خضراء انها اذا
اردت ان تحول الاقتصاد
المعاصر الكثيف المعقد العالمي الموصول
بكل الدنيا اذا اردت ان تحوله الى
الاقتصاد اسلامي فهذا زعم كبير
ويحتاج الى دوره حضاريه الذي حدث في الغرب
منذ القرن السادس عشر ان هنالك نهضه
حضاريه كامله كما حدث في القرون الاسلاميه
الاولى لكن مثل بسيط جدا في السودان مثلا
اكثر ما كانوا يهتمون به هو التربيه
واعاده صياغه الانسان السوداني ولكن سلم
المناهج التعليم بالكامل لمده 30 عاما في
كل مكان اتضح ان كل دول العالم العربي
تقريبا سلموا مناج التعليم يعني هذه
الجماعات
نعم صدقت نعم نعم اغلبهم كانوا معلمين
وانتشروا ولكن في السودان القرار نفسه
القرار السياسي المتحكم في المناهج كان في
يد الحركه الاسلاميه
ولكنها لم تولي التعليم هذا الاهتمام الذي
يستحقه رغم انها تحدثت عن ثوره التعليم
والمفارقه هو ان الجيل الذي خرج بالملايين
واسقط الانغاز وخريج هذا المنهج فانا
اسميته منهج الشيعي والتقديس كان يهتم بان
يقدس المعلومات في ذهن الطالب بتحفيظه
[موسيقى]
مقدارها هائل من الاحاديث والايات ولكن
هذا هذه الشيئيه والتقدير ذات عند اول
اختبار عند اول مواجهه
الانسان السوداني
كانت حقيقه عده مواجهات محدوده في في خاصه
في السنوات الاخيره التي ترت انفصال
الجنوب في عام 2012 قامت ثوره محدوده في
يونيو ثم في 2013 كانت هناك اوسع في
سبتمبر ثم انفجر الامر في ديسمبر 2019
انفجر السودان كله ونزل الى الشوارع الى
نسقط الانقاذ اغلب الذين خرجوا خاصه في
البدايه وتحملوا
الوطى الاولى الشديده وطئه الرصاص والعنف
البالغ الذي مارسته الاجهزه الامنيه كانوا
من الشباب من الاجيال الصغيره جدا خريجي
هذه المدارس وخرجيها هذه المناهج وحتى هم
تحدثوا عن ذلك بعض قاده الانقاذ انساك
تحدثوا اننا ينبغي ان لا نخاف من هذه
المظاهرات للذين خرجوا خريجين هذه المدارس
وهذه مجرد مؤامره شيوعيه ويساريه وبعثيه
تريد ان تضلل هؤلاء الشباب ولكن علينا ان
نصل ونخاط بهم وطبعا هذا كان خطاب متاخر
لانه انت كان بامكانك ان تعيد فعلا صياغه
الانسان السوداني الذي استلمته منذ
المرحله ما قبل التعليم المدرسي منذ رياض
الاطفال ان تستلمته ولكن لم تستطع ان تحول
انا ضربت مثل بالتعليم